people would say wow you're so brave
you're so empowered
i can't write all these songs without
obviously having been disempowered
we couldn't get signed everybody
rejected us it's too in your face it's
too emotional i am that right now and
when i'm 34 and you won't get a record
like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was there room for alanis and rock no
but you try and ignore the song you're
not gonna write a better song than you
ought to know they put in the cassette
tape within 30 seconds everything
changed
and it just went nuclear man it was like
it went
[Applause]
empowerment as a young woman in the 90s
singing about it was not good news for
the patriarchy
you were just immediately shut down
when you are the only woman in a male
dominated environment it's very
complicated and complex
her brutal honesty empowered women it
gave you a chance to let out your own
feelings
this is a female artist that transcended
gender where dudes could be like i feel
the same way
without even knowing i was doing it i
was carving out my voice this is dream
come true stuff
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you